foreign
I was employed as a secretary in a
shipping and travel agency
and I like the job a lot and then after
we got married I had to stop working
and even if I wanted to
I couldn't
keep on working because that was the law
when my husband passed away with these
three quarters of his pension I found it
hard
60 years ago marriage and children often
meant women couldn't pursue a career
potentially leaving them struggling
financially later in life
but can women in today's EU say they
have a healthy work-life balance
this European Parliament has ensured
professional and home lives can coexist
and is fighting to guarantee that equal
work means equal pay we are showing
clearly the gender pay Gap that women
are learning less doing the same work
that the pensions at the end of the they
are lower for women because they were
paid less
to promote equal pay Parliament also
wants to make it easier for employees
within the same company to compare
salaries
meanwhile MEPS are working to advance
women's rights as human rights We Are
One equality Union and we should not
have different rights for women since we
decided about so many standards on so
many fields we should also bring one
standard common European Standard for
women's rights and gender equality that
means better access to jobs in the
boardroom
greater representation in science and
technology
and strategies to protect women from all
types of violence we have domestic
violence and abuse you've all forms of
sexual violence you have prostitution
you have trafficking you have female
genital mutilation and you have forced
marriage and child marriage we've been
watching very closely and welcome the
fact that the EU is moving to create a
directive a new directive on combating
violence against women so we we see the
value very much of the EU playing its
part and kind of setting a tone in this
regard
[Music]